il indique n'était plus amoureux à
partir du moment où ces modèles devenez
l'aide sousse en passant je sais pas qui
c'était mais en tout cas il l'aimait
vraiment plus
il n'y a pas tout ça c'est moi c'est
votre job vous êtes un autre peintre
c'est ce que j'aimerais faire l'est dans
la vie je suis serveuse tu es toujours
acteur toujours oui et là je fais juste
une petite pause parce que je me
consacre à l'écriture une peintre est un
acteur capable avait des gros séparés
tuco dit que quelque chose à mettre
dedans
tacopina l'air très sympa on s'est
connus en cours d'ébénisterie tu fais
d'ébénisterie qua non et toi cécilia tu
reconnaissante envers toi je préfère
garder ma reconnaissance pour manette
merci avant de passer vous chercher pour
aller dîner
j'ai créé une petite histoire ferry et
de quoi ça parle d'une première
rencontre cauchemardesque
croyez vous vraiment que les hommes et
les femmes doivent toujours se prêter un
jeu mais jean pierre jeunet plage de
jouer je voudrais visiter ce corps que
vous cachez il s'est passé quoi
exactement
le gars est mort
la truck en emménagent ensemble oui ça
me fait un peu peur qu'on s'installe
ensemble mais c'est pour ça que je veux
m'installer avec toi parce que tu me
mets le nez dedans mais c'est aussi la
raison pour laquelle j'ai la trouille de
m'installer avec toi et que l'est ce
costume celui du mec à poil dans un
tonneau pourquoi je sais pas depuis
quelques temps je trouve qu'il ya comme
une distance qui s'installe entre nous
donc toutes relations hantées a d'un
côté celui qui aime et de l'autre celui
qu'on aime et c'est toujours celle il
acquiert parte je veux en afrique bâtir
des maisons et des écoles pour les
familles déshéritées de namibie y est tu
as tourné autour comme une vraie
midinettes
c'était long c'est quelqu'un qui a
toujours besoin qu'on rassure tout va
ils cherchent pas attention à tes c'est
les acteurs je voudrais qu'elle passe ou
that and on lâche tu arrêtes tout de
suite mexes as aimé
bon le flanc c'est quoi on reste habillé
toute la soirée ça va toi c'est un fait
remarquer alors c'est pas juste que tu
avais grossi
un type a dit un jour mieux vaut avoir
perdu l'amour que de ne l'avoir jamais
trouvé je lui balance serait bien mon
poing dans la gueule à celui-là je dois
reconnaître qu'il a raison parce que
malgré le désespoir et la douleur quand
c'est bien quand c'est vraiment bien
alors ça vaut le coup
[Musique]